we're in a cost of living crisis fueled
by high food and energy prices and now
there's a labor shortage too a shortage
of people to do the jobs that are needed
to keep the uk economy growing so what
are the government going to do about it
ministers say they have a plan i met the
work and pension secretary trace coffee
for a bird's eye view of the capital and
to find out what that plan is
trade coffee thanks for coming on the
show although we're in a pod not in the
studio which actually i think i prefer
i think i should do all my interviews in
here but anyway that's a whole different
thing um look thanks for coming on the
show
uh i went back to the last time we did a
sit down and i interviewed you it was
just after the fast lockdown it was in
october 2020 you were preparing at the
department for potentially four million
people
unemployed and at the heart of the final
quarter of that year redundancies were
the highest level at the highest level
on record you'll remember it fast
forward two years
we've now got record on employment job
vacancies are at record numbers to 1.3
million and we've got shortages in
certain sectors can you unpack it a bit
for me about what's going on because the
market looks quite confusing
well of course when we went into covid
we didn't quite know what the impact was
going to be uh what we did know is that
we had to close down significant parts
of the economy and in particular people
um who may be on quite low incomes so
whether it's hospitality retail and
that's why we prepared and we're ready
and absorbed actually a record number of
uc claimants coming in who needed help
at the time so fast forward that we
recruited people to help people get
ready to get back into work you know we
had a few fits and starts and during the
pandemic but i think what was important
was obviously the importance of the
furlough scheme so a lot of people
stayed attached to their employers but
also as we started to get vacancies
coming we were well placed uh having
built that relationship with uh
claimants to get them ready and to get
them into work but we needed quite a big
shove i think at the beginning of this
year because we did have record and
still have huge numbers of vacancies and
we just needed to make sure learning
from what we did with kickstart with
young people
getting that right across our entire
claimant group
so you've got more people into work but
what people watching will be seeing are
shortages in industries i went to
my dad's village in norfolk over the
jubilee weekend and the local pub had
shut down because they couldn't get
staff
aviation shortages you know mayhem in
airports
what's going on in terms of shortages
because it's not an immigration issue if
you actually look at the figures 18 of
the current workforce are immigrants
that's the highest proportion ever so so
what what's going on why are there so
many vacancies
well we've got a half a million people
into work in just the last five months
and
learning by bringing employers into our
job centre um making sure that we got
rapid turnaround with decisions and uh
coaching people if they hadn't uh hadn't
been successful but i think more broadly
what we've seen of the 1.3 million
vacancies quite a lot of those are high
skill you're right and uh that's uh we
need to keep working now on how we bring
people out of economic inactivity and
that's why i'll be working and i'm
working with other departments across
government how we make that happen i
don't think it is about more immigration
or immigration for certain sectors do
you think do you accept that or you
don't
well one of the things that we have is
the migration advisory committee uh in
regards to thinking about high-skilled
jobs where we don't have sufficiently
enough people and that was one of the
things of leaving the european union we
were able to move to our points-based
immigration system uh we have seen a lot
of people come into the country but
thinking a little bit more broadly you
know you were talking about rural
norfolk and aspects of that what we've
done for example and i give you a great
example and madison and kent we brought
together farmers uh we brought together
uh our claimants and we actually did
some uh kind of trials some work coach
experience and we actually started
filling jobs in those sort of fruit
pressings picking areas so we can make
it happen by bringing our employees
together and that's been the success of
way to work and
choice coffee in terms of where we are
now we've got 1.3 million vacancies but
the other thing that is quite
surprising i find surprising is that we
have
5.3 million people one in four
people of working age in this country
are either unemployed or economically
inactive and claiming some sort of
benefits that's an astonishing figure i
was surprised by that what
what's going on well this also includes
people who aren't uh medically capable
of working it also
includes people uh with caring
responsibilities so there'll be a
variety of reasons of people who are job
ready in order to do that
well we have seen uh we now have a
record of three million people
on pip of disability benefit if you
think about it 5.3 million people
economically inactive 1.3 million job
vacancies if you get one out of five of
those people back into work
you fix the problem right without
further immigration is that your aim is
that the goal well my focus is on the
about 1.4 million people who we pay
benefits to who are actively looking for
work and as we've talked about some of
the
vacancies may not be readily accessible
for those people but when i think about
some of where we're trying to fill
vacancies around the country we are also
needing employers to be flexible this is
about where we are trying to help people
who have got some challenging health
conditions and how we can help them get
into work in a more proactive way
but nevertheless uh beth there's a
number of people who went on furlough
seem to have saved a lot of money
haven't necessarily wanted to go back to
the jobs they were doing before it maybe
they found a job during furlough uh
another job which was more to their
suiting but i think we've seen a greater
thing of people um being
uh kind of wanting a different life work
balance yeah people watching this will
be thinking about their summer holidays
and looking at the baggage claim at
heathrow in absolute horror thinking is
my holiday going to get messed up
because of worker shortages the airlines
are calling out for a temporary visa
scheme
to try and sort out this short-term
issue would you rule out a temporary
visa the reason i'm asking is because
people are watching going i just want it
fixed you know i want to go on holiday i
want it fixed well indeed about i don't
believe that uh the visa route is what
is uh being considered within government
i just know that we are helping people
currently who are out of work to find
jobs in our airports around the country
ons figures out today use uk household
incomes filed for a fourth consecutive
quarter at the start of the year it's
the longest rung decline in household
income since
1955.
adjusted for inflation incomes were 1.3
percent lower than a year ago
well look we know that inflation is high
and we know it's having an impact that's
why we responded with the cost of living
uh payment that we've taken i mean but
we've added an extra 15 billion pounds
uh the first payments will be going out
to low-income households next month uh
and that be staggered throughout the
year in how we help people as well as
the money going to every household to
help with energy costs is it difficult
in your job though because
you are dealing with people that are
really at the bottom of income scales
that typically that they feel
price-wise is much more acutely than the
middle classes because they don't have
disposable income do you is it hard in
your job that you think i can't do
enough for people
well i do know that one of the best ways
i can help them is to help them get a
job yeah
to really boost their pay packet but i
remember in the pandemic your department
really pushed for example the 20 pounds
a week on universal credit that that
made a huge difference to people that
was a way you could cost 6 billion a
year
i mean
do you kind of think if i could i would
put that policy back
i don't anticipate a particular up
rating that's uh linked to 20 pounds but
as ever i will do my annual review uh
later in the year i interview gordon
brown also this week for the show and
he's a former chancellor and thinks a
lot about this too and he said to me
that he's worried that charity is
becoming the last line of defense for
people struggling instead of the welfare
state
what's your response to that do you
think that's an unfair
observation as i've pointed out we've
put together just uh in a matter of a
few weeks ago less than two months ago a
package of support of 15 billion pounds
to help and some of the criticism of it
was that it wasn't targeted enough that
those on lower incomes that it wasn't
targets enough like some of the blanket
measures like a fuel duty cut 6 billion
2.4 billion pounds for that but it was
well that was part of the earlier
package in terms of uh the 22 billion
pounds before okay well let's let's talk
a bit now about you
um now before you came into politics you
were you're a scientist by background
aren't you well i did a phd in chemistry
but i didn't carry it on in work and
then you're a business woman yeah
but did you always want to go into
politics were you a young conservative
i was a young conservative i think i
grew up in liverpool in the 80s and
i'm 50 now but actually as a child i did
actually have a conservative mp people
might find that hard to believe it
wasn't for very long
and then i felt my home city of
liverpool was ruined by militant labor
and the analogy i can see with momentum
today and recently is very
very clear
and i just realized that politics
mattered
both my parents were teachers they were
the gang part of the gang that received
their redundancy notice which was then
repealed and i remember at the time
saying to my mum this is like really
worrying she said no don't worry it's
some trick so they can we'll all get
we'll all be fine and i just thought
that's not the way to run my city and i
actually thought margaret thatcher was
doing a great job in the rest of the
country so i got engaged i didn't know
that i didn't know you were from
liverpool actually you haven't got a
liverpool accent at all i can turn on
the other side okay
i went to paris for the uh
for the uh champions league final so it
was good too i did so i didn't know this
about you i'll tell you getting into the
stadium it's like being in a mosh pit
that wasn't right wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't there was it loads of aggro there
did you get it i think it's very well
handled but did you find did you have
any troubles there were you absolutely i
wasn't pepper sprayed but uh that was
part of the squash honestly it was like
being in a mosh pit but you didn't want
to be
oh no it wasn't great
it wasn't frightened but it was
uncomfortable
but nevertheless it was um it wasn't
even a great result for us the other
thing that i know about you but lots of
people might not know about you is that
you're also a devoted roman catholic
now in terms of your faith does it
affect your or guide political decisions
for you at all or is it something that
you keep for sunday only is it is do you
separate those things out in your life
well i don't work i don't think i wear
my religion on my sleeve so to speak but
it's undoubtedly a part of who i am
and i hope that comes through in a lot
of the ways that we try and help people
in my role as secretary of state we want
to be compassionate and considered
in what we're doing and helping some of
the most vulnerable people in our
society
you know there are other issues which
get decided in parliament on great
ethical issues of the day
and so of course i'll participate in
that but i'm a democrat as well and i
just realized we're coming down so i'm
going to jump to this straight to this
question just in terms of women's rights
roe versus wade uh last week the supreme
court and mere effect the end the
constitute rights were abortion for
millions of women across the u.s the pm
said it was a move backwards step
backwards what did you think about that
well it's a us supreme court decision in
this country parliament's legislated to
allow access to abortion uh there it's a
different uh debate uh federal
uh versus uh states and the supreme
court have come a different decision on
who should decide that is it the courts
or should it be legitimate we already
have the situation so abortion law isn't
going to change in this country people
will still have access to it jacob
rees-mogg the reason was he we were he's
obviously a
catholic too he told me that the number
of abortions in the uk he thought was
one of the saddest aspects of british
modern life
do you agree with that
i think there's a number of things where
people either give up hope or don't
think they can cope with certain things
in a broad
varieties of way
of course i would prefer for people who
didn't have abortions but i'm not going
to condemn people that do and would you
like to see
the rights to abortion shined in british
law which is now the live debate we
don't need it because we already have
legislation that provides access to
abortion and just finally
you've i've been described as one of the
fully paid up human beings in public
life you like a drink you like a bit of
karaoke you occasionally like a cigar
um
that's your way of letting off steam
isn't it what's your signature track oh
gosh i don't know it keeps changing one
of the we're having a great time at the
moment it's shower and becky g
there we go dancing in the mirror
singing in the shower but no that's a
slightly different thing a few years ago
i was pretty ill it's reinforced my
joy for life
and i'll keep living life to the full
but i'm a professional always get the
work done